[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All
right, now, it's time
to learn about all the new, cool
stuff with Google Play Console.
And I'm here with Matt
to tell us all about it.
MATT: Hey everybody.
We're super excited to be here.
I/O is a big moment for
us with the Play Console
because we're all
about developers.
As you probably know,
the Play Console
is what developers use to
publish their apps to Android
devices through the Play Store.
And what we've seen
is over the years
we've gone from a Play
Console, which was simply
about getting an
app from A to B,
from the developer to
the end consumer's phone.
Now, it's so much more.
There's really a
hugely diverse set
of tools that enable
developers to be
more successful with their app.
And what we've found
is that the user base
has diversified as well.
In addition to our core
audience of Android developers,
we have product managers,
marketing managers.
Many other users
wearing different hats
in the organization are
starting to use the tool.
At I/O this year,
we're announcing
a whole new set of
features, as well as
updates to some of our
popular existing features.
In some cases, these
features are helping apps
to be higher quality.
And so, we're launching
Android Vitals,
which is a whole new set of
reporting about bad experiences
on the Android device.
So these are a user experience
where your app may be crashing,
or your app may be
rendering in a slow way
or you may have excessive wake
ups, stuck wake locks that
are causing excessive
drainage on batteries.
So we're going to
start revealing
that reporting to developers
that can help them to debug,
understand more about optimizing
their app for the variety
of devices that are out there.
And that's one of many different
new features we're launching.
Another one, actually
you can see on the screen
behind me is the device catalog.
So Android's diverse ecosystem
has been a tremendous strength
and source of the scale
of the two billion Android
devices that are out there now.
But that diverse
ecosystem can also
be hard to navigate and
understand for developers
until now because the device
catalog is a much easier way
to browse the more than
1,000 different Android
certified devices.
You can search and explore
these devices by spec like ram,
like system on chip, and you can
then see reporting information
about the number of
installs your app has
on that particular device
or on that group of devices,
how much revenue you're getting,
how your ratings compare,
which can really help you
to understand whether any
of the bad behaviors,
any of these problems
that users may be having with
your app are concentrated
in a particular
area, which can be
critical to
optimizing and making
your app super high quality.
So we're finding-- even just
in the initial testing, which
we've now completed, this
feature is rolling out
to all developers-- we found
out early testers have really
embraced these tools.
It's really helping
them to be much more
surgical in the way they think
about targeting their app
and making it a great
experience for the end user.
In addition to the features that
help developers to build higher
quality apps, we've
also got a number
of features which
help to mitigate risk
during the release process.
And so, when you're releasing
a new version of your app,
you may have an install base
of millions, potentially
hundreds of millions of users.
If you're pushing out a
new version of your app,
it can otherwise
be a worrying time.
You don't want to know that
bugs are causing uninstalls.
You don't want to know
that information late.
So we have a new
release dashboard
with very low latency
reporting that
helps you to have visibility
of these metrics on the hour,
every hour as it's
starting to roll out,
to a potentially global
audience of hundreds
of millions of devices.
And so, this can help you
to manage your release
with a lot more confidence.
A third area where we are
launching new features right
here at I/O is in
the business area.
And so, developers, in
addition to building
amazing experiences,
they want to make money.
They want to grow
their business.
We have a lot of new
reporting including
for app developers that have
a subscription-based model.
You can look at
subscription by tenure,
look at cohorts from
when they've started,
when they've installed
the app, and how that
lifecycle trends over time.
You can help to see how
different inflection points are
contributing to subscription
renewals or people
leaving a subscription.
So it can really help you
to manage your subscription
business.
And then, in general,
we have a lot
of statistics that are available
through the Play Console.
In the past, they weren't
always easily navigable.
We have a new configurable
statistics page.
And with that page,
developers are
much more easily able to
slice and dice these metrics,
create custom configurations,
to compare different time
periods against each other,
to compare one metric
against another,
and to introduce benchmarks
of whole classes of apps
so they can see how
some of their reporting
compares to peers who
make similar apps.
And so we think that
features like this
will really help developers to
manage their apps as a business
as well.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Wow.
That was a lot of stuff.
Thank you so much, Matt.
MATT: Thank you.